[Musica]
buonasera a tutti
sono persi internet ho riscritto le cose
che volevo condividere con voi questa
sera negli ultimi giorni quando mi hanno
chiesto di partecipare al ted era subito
prima dell'estate e sono successe un
sacco di cose ne prendo tre che sono
comparsi nel mio cellulare
nelle ultime settimane i talebani hanno
preso kabul e hanno cominciato una
campagna di manipolazione comunicativa
online all'interno dei social media
abbiamo visto aumentare la tossicità
dell'ambiente comunicativo online
all'interno di internet
parlando di
masque non mask green park lo green pass
e fino agli ultimi giorni alle ultime
ore è pensato penso solamente a ieri
abbiamo visto criticare aumentare
diciamo l'odio online per un ragazzo che
si candida alla al comune di roma e che
indossava in una foto un orologio molto
costoso quando ci siamo persi internet
cioè internet era così anche prima ho
qualcosa è capitato ora prova a
raccontarvelo con una storia che la mia
storia io sono entrato come dire n i
contenuti generati dagli utenti nel 2004
con un blog collettivo era e non eravamo
tantissimi in italia però stringevamo
relazione fra di noi ha conosciuto un
sacco di gente
ho conosciuto come delle persone a
livello nazionale e internazionale
riuscivamo a scambiarci informazioni e
raccontarci delle cose forse era un
mondo come dire più pacificato non
c'erano tantissime persone ma già lì
cominciano i primi contrasti fra la
blogosfera e i giornalisti
nel 2007 ho aperto il mio primo account
su twitter
twitter come dire per mettere ancora di
parlare in 140 caratteri e ci si
esprimeva in terza persona che una cosa
molto ridicola anche facebook all'inizio
come dire era così qualcuno di voi
ricorderà era era un mondo diverso anche
qui c'erano gli early adopters un po in
tutto il mondo e cioè le prime persone
che entravano in rete che si raccontano
un po di tutto dai fatti quotidiani come
dire a il commento delle notizie
internazionali internet diventato
qualcosa di più serio nel 2010 qualcuno
di voi si ricorderà alle rivoluzioni
arabe e come gli attivisti abbiano
cominciato a manifestare aggiungendo
come dire ai cartelli sulle loro armi
rivoluzionarie c'è anzi cancellando le
armi di tipo tradizionale aggiungendo
due social media come twitter e facebook
e nel 2010 che hillary clinton che
segretario di stato nel governo obama
dichiara nel gennaio 2010 dobbiamo
mettere questi strumenti nelle mani di
persone che li usino per il progresso
della democrazia e dei diritti umani
forse un po troppo ingenuo un po troppo
infatti che questa posizione come dire
ma questo è l'approccio di internet
immaginato all'inizio che cosa è
successo dopo cioè quando ci siamo persi
internet nel 2010 gli amici di wired
hanno candidato
internet al nobel
una follia a pensarlo
oggi eravamo come dire pochi mesi dopo
le rivoluzioni
arabe c'era molto entusiasmo e tutti i
media erano molto attenti alla portata a
rivoluzionare chi internet avrebbe
potuto avere è un immaginario
un'immaginazione che abbiamo cominciato
a dimenticare molto presto allora quelle
che ci siamo persi internet internet
abbiamo cominciato a perderlo quasi da
subito già nel 2010 con i primi user
generated content le cose che più e
venivano condivisi dalle persone online
e che erano queste
forse internet abbiamo cominciato a
perderlo nel momento in cui l'umanità
rimaste imbrigliate nei gattini
osama bin laden
quando è stato ucciso all'interno del
suo rifugio la cia racconta sé ma un
racconto abbastanza attendibile che nel
suo computer tenesse diversi video di
gattini su internet allora ovviamente
come dire le cose non cominciano solo
così in un test molto famoso la
produzione dei gattini viene visto come
uno dei primi elementi che ci permette
di diventare attivi e partecipativi
nella rete abbiamo scherzato abbiamo
come dire cominciato con video molto
divertenti abbiamo continuato così
con tante varianti fondamentalmente ma
in fondo come dire eravamo tutto sommato
ancora felici all'interno di questo tipo
di di realtà le cose andavano bene ci
scambiavamo informazioni di diverso tipo
ci davamo il buongiorno alla mattina o
insistentemente a ogni ora con giorni
simo caffè che alcuni di voi avranno
subito ma in qualche maniera si sembrava
tutto ancora molto bello e molto
interessante ricordo una persona che era
davanti a me nel dicembre del 2012
quindi in prossimità del natale
in un ipermercato che voleva comprare un
computer e che chiedeva alla persona che
lo stava vendendo vorrei comprare un
computer basta che vada su facebook e
possa vedere dei video divertenti ok
internet era già diventata quella cosa
lì stacco arriviamo ad oggi cresce su
internet il livello di inciviltà le
ricerche come dire ci raccontano che in
italia il livello di inciviltà
ricresciuta il 66 per cento c'è molta
più intolleranza nei confronti degli
altri molta più violenza verbale
aggressione come dire nei confronti
specialmente delle delle donne è un
livello come dire tossico che viene
percepito dalle persone queste sono le
percezioni delle persone cresce anche il
livello di polarizzazione durante
vi ricordate il tema della della
ingresso dell uscita cioè del the main o
dell'uscita degli ok all'interno
dell'unione europea durante quelle
settimane il livello di polarizzazione
online era molto molto alto e una serie
di bot cioè di sistemi automatici su
internet hanno promosso la break sit in
maniera molto forte forte ripetendo
continuamente tweet mostrando in qualche
maniera che la popolazione era a favore
dell'uscita una polarizzazione che come
dire si unisce a una manipolazione molto
forte disinformazione quelle che abbiamo
cominciato a credere a qualsiasi cosa
venisse
scritta online questa è una notizia
falsa una bufala di pochi giorni fa e
che ci racconta come fighter starebbe
progettando un vaccino che ci
riporterebbe a prima del vaccino
annullando gli effetti del vaccino sul
nostro corpo e quindi risanando c
completamente è circolata moltissimo è
falsa ovviamente ma molte persone
l'hanno condivisa come vere come
attendibile oppure quand'è che sono
successe delle cose tipo queste questi
liliana segre viene postata un'immagine
in cui lei si avvicina e si scatena come
dire una campagna d'odio online con
persone che ci mettono la faccia insomma
faccia i nomi che io ho cancellato in
qualche maniera ma che in qualche modo
si esprimono in maniera molto forte
contro un'altra persona quando è che
abbiamo perso internet perché ci siamo
persi internet che cos'è capitato
fondamentalmente due cose internet è
diventato di massa
rispetto all'inizio la maggior parte
delle popolazioni in sono entrate su
internet la maggior parte delle persone
portando le loro istanze le loro
diversità internet funziona come la
gravità ci mette più vicini gli uni agli
altri quando siamo vicini alle persone
li vediamo come dire più in profondità
nel bene e nel male più persone vediamo
da vicino e più vediamo un'umanità che
si racconta in maniera molto diversa
nel bene e nel male secondo i social
media le piattaforme internet è
diventato un mondo di piattaforme le
piattaforme sono i custodi di internet
hanno saturato
l'orizzonte sociale e tecnologico di
internet
comprare qualche cosa informarsi su
qualche cosa scambiare delle chiacchiere
con qualcuno significa passare da delle
piattaforme molti di voi dai vostri
cellulari non passano più da internet
vanno direttamente nelle a andare su
facebook significa per una pander su
instagram per un'app andare su twitter
aprire una app non si passa da internet
siamo all'interno di walid gardens
giardini chiusi ben curati spesso che in
qualche maniera controllano quello che
avviene all'interno e lo fanno
attraverso il controllo del flusso delle
informazioni che avviene tramite gli
algoritmi allora senza esagerare gli
algoritmi non sono il male ma sono un
modo di gestire noi all'interno della
rete gli algoritmi hanno il compito di
tradurre i nostri in comportamenti in
d'arte si parla di dati ficazione un
esempio uno dei più semplici
facebook ha aumentato il numero di
reaction di reazioni che possiamo avere
un post per modulare la nostra
sensibilità raccogliere il dato e
poterlo utilizzare prima potevate fare
like oggi vi potete esprimere ma
attraverso uno di questi sei emoji
fondamentalmente questo permette di
tradurre quello che noi siamo in una
serie di dati che poi possono essere
utilizzati a fini commerciali facebook
che ha fatto alcuni anni fa un
esperimento un po controverso sul
contagio emotivo dimostrando manipolando
i diciamo i contenuti che le persone
potevano vedere quindi facendo vedere
una parte le persone sono contenuti
negativi da una parte le persone sono
contenuti positivi e ha mostrato che
persone che vedevano contenuti negativi
postavano eri condividevano contenuti
negativi in qualche maniera il loro
rumore peggiorava quindi questo contagio
emotivo che è presente in rete anche
attraverso la visibilità delle cose che
gli algoritmi ci mostrano è
particolarmente evidente una ricerca
fatta su youtube mostra come all'interno
di youtube i contenuti più controversi
quelli che sono più problematici tendano
a diventare quelli più visibili online
in pratica gli algoritmi come dire sono
più lago ritmo come dire raccoglie lodi
e più funzionale algoritmo rispetto alla
alla felicità quindi come dire i
contenuti più violenti e più forti sono
quelli che tenderanno a diventare per
come funzionano le logiche delle
piattaforme più visibili l'ambiente
diventa quindi più tossico è un ambiente
come dire online che è più tossico che
era caratterizzato da inciviltà
disinformazione polarizzazione e e odio
si tratta di capire se questi sono cause
o sono sintomi cioè o che è colpa di
internet
dipende da internet dipende da qualche
cos'altro
quello che vorrei raccontare questa sera
gli ultimi minuti che mi rimangono è che
ci troviamo di fronte a una crisi in
qualche maniera
energetica del digitale a un vero e
proprio internet warming a un
riscaldamento di internet che dipende da
una serie di comportamenti che vengono
tenuti online ora come ci riprendiamo
internet
facciamo così quanti di voi hanno
instagram qua in sala un account swift
non praticamente quasi tutti cosa si fa
su instagram molte cose no si fotografa
il proprio outfit si mostra che si sono
fatti dei viaggi prima della pandemia
anche durante la pandemia si fotografano
piatti cibi il food porn come hashtag
sicuramente come dire lo conoscete tutti
condividiamo di nuovo gattini insomma
non è cambiato tantissimo diciamo da dal
2010 ma mostriamo anche quanto siamo
abili a mostrare cose interessanti e
artistiche e in qualche maniera non
mostriamo le nostre competenze online
quindi internet serve e instagram e in
particolare per fare condividere
guardare fotografie giusto
ok sbagliata instagram come internet
serve a fare rete questo è il punto da
cui partire cioè quei contenuti che
pubblichiamo online sono contenuti che
servono a creare relazioni con gli altri
internet enough nasce e continua ad
essere un luogo in cui facciamo rete
cosa che condividiamo online
fondamentalmente esperienze internet è
un luogo virtuale digitale immateriale
chiamatelo come vi pare in cui
incontriamo però delle persone reali i
contenuti hanno detto delle persone
fondamentalmente quando noi ce la
prendiamo con un contenuto ci dobbiamo
chiedere se dietro quel contenuto non ci
sia una persona che invece vorremmo
rispettare in qualche maniera come dire
questo è il contesto in cui viviamo ma
che richiede rispetto riscaldamento di
internet così come riscaldamento globale
di cambiare comportamenti come nella
vita reale fondamentalmente online le
relazioni sono il cuore sono quello che
cementa tutto quindi non è internet
siamo noi siamo anche noi questi sono
sintomi di cause di violenza o di
inciviltà eccetera che riguardano noi
come società che dobbiamo affrontare gli
ambienti non sono tossici in sé per sé
sono le persone tossiche che producono
tossicità nell'ambiente e online
dobbiamo difenderci dagli elementi
tossici
come ricordava prima la speaker che mi
ha introdotto io sono fra i fondatori
del progetto parole ostili e con un
manifesto in dieci punti abbiamo cercato
di raccontare gli elementi principali
che possono riequilibrare il nostro modo
di stare con le parole su internet il
processo educativo è tra i più lunghi e
tra i più difficili a che fare con i
comportamenti sociali se abbiamo
imparato a fare raccolta differenziata
della nostra immondizia forse possiamo
imparare a fare raccolta indifferenziata
di contenuti su internet servirà del
tempo ma ci possiamo educare ma non
basta serve un passaggio in più
ci dobbiamo chiedere dobbiamo discutere
quali tipo di discorso pubblico e
comportamento siamo disposti ad
accettare online offline e di che tipo
di società vogliamo essere questo come
dire è un momento di fronte alla
all'internet warning questa è la domanda
che ci dobbiamo fare queste sono le
domande che ci dobbiamo fare dobbiamo
modificare in modo di pensare alle
piattaforme
dobbiamo pensare i social media le
piattaforme sempre di più come
infrastrutture che siano pubbliche che
sono possedute moderate le comunità che
le abitano la manutenzione le
piattaforme le possono più fare
piattaforme stessi siamo noi ci dobbiamo
assumere una responsabilità all'interno
di questo tipo di realtà nel nostro
piccolo non mettendo like una reaction
ha un contenuto che non ci piace
particolarmente
leggendo i contenuti prima di
condividerli in qualche maniera come
dire modificando dei piccoli
comportamenti quotidiani per riprenderci
internet l'internet worming in qualche
maniera si combatte così ripartendo in
qualche maniera da noi e modificando il
nostro modo di pensare alla rete per
come la rete sia strutturata fino adesso
ci troviamo di fronte allo stesso tipo
di tensione che abbiamo con il
cambiamento climatico
solo che questo cambiamento riguarda
internet che riguarda noi gli unici
antin corpi in rete siamo noi siamo noi
come dire che possiamo lavorare su
questi sintomi diventare dei veri e
propri anticorpi per quello che succede
lì all'interno e quindi come dire è su
questi anticorpi che possiamo contare su
noi stessi per modificare quello che
sarà internet nei prossimi dieci anni
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]